welcome to the premiere episode of
strategy session with Jonathan schranz
there was a lot of good name suggestion
for what this this class could be so I
just want to want to mention what this
could have been called but those like
all the ideas that you guys submitted
they all got rejected the one I really
liked was France's stupendous strategy
show so that would have been a cool name
for a class also shrunk strats now that
seems like a good one for like gamers
and stuff and even a one I did try to
get also a strategy made simple I
thought that was a good one so you guys
came up with some good names but they
all got rejected so it's a nice try so
this will be strategy session and for
this first episode I thought we'd go
over the theme of identifying and
controlling key squares so what we were
here and we had the US Chess
Championship going on it was another big
tournament going on in Norway which
Magnus Carlsen won
and one of the games he played was
against kramnik and that's the game
we're going to go over and at one point
we'll will pause and we'll let the
audience try to identify the key squares
and see if you guys can play like Magnus
so in this game it was a Queens gambit
declined and he probably saw my video so
he played the exchange variation and we
get this normal position and in this
position kramnik played Bishop to f5
which is not the main move but it's a
favorite of Nigel short and other
players that have had some decent
success with it okay Bishop to e7 is
more popular but one of the things that
I can do immediately is the move Queen
to f3 and you get this position where
white can give up the bishop pair to
double the pawns so this is sort of the
starting position for this variation and
so you got the the weakened pawn
structure but you have the two bishops
and given enough time and it's a
relatively closed position this Knight
may
maneuver itself 2d6 where it'll be
looking in at some of the light squares
which is sort of the key maneuver that
black plays in this position usually and
we'll go just a couple moves here and
now Carlson in this position did
something that's not unknown in this
position but the way in which he
achieved it was a novel way to play here
so just take a few minutes here look at
this position and try to identify some a
key square that Carlson might be able to
fight for control of and then we'll see
what you guys have to say and in just a
minute here I'll give you guys a hint so
all right now and before anybody says
anything hopefully you guys have some
sort of ideas in your mind here I want
to give you a hint so I'm going to get
rid of this for just a second we'll come
back and I want to show you this
position which is the same position only
without any pieces and this is sort of a
good method for trying to come up with
plans in the middle game is to first
imagine the board with just the palm
structure and then where you should put
your pieces will depend on where the
pawns are so if you look just at this
position which is you know devoid of all
the pieces perhaps it'll be a little bit
easier to identify certain key squares
that could potentially be weak and then
white could hope to occupy so now I'll
ask the audience here are there any
squares you guys notice that are
potentially weak or the white could
potentially control f5 excellent right
so f5 is the the key square here so when
this pawn moves you know because it was
doubled whoa Wow
I don't know how it did that so I can't
drag it but since you no longer have the
Jeep on a lot of these squares along the
F file we'll make them different colors
so you can see f5 is is the key square
here are a lot weaker because you don't
have a pawn that could potentially
control those squares but f5 is
definitely the right answer so let's
jump back to the game real quick
we'll see so now we we know the square
that we're looking for but now we need
to come up with a plan how is white
going to get control over f5 so let's
think about it with the pieces here ok
very good
and that was indeed the first move and
okay so black one here so you got one
piece there but how are you going to get
more pieces to control f5 yeah the main
move here is actually g3 but Carlson
played a novelty and it's it's a pretty
good one so I imagine players with the
white pieces will start using this
strategy in this position king d2 just
with the idea of Bishop d3 okay and even
if I if I give it to you
let's okay so then yeah you want to be
able to put something there okay that's
interesting I think it's like a I mean I
can keep doing my maneuver and then you
just want to go there immediately with
something
mm-hmm yes so not quite mm-hmm let's get
yeah so at some point yeah the bishop
will probably end up going to d3
g4 okay this move will probably be
played at some point I wasn't played
immediately okay now as you know if
there's any way to really punish it
maybe there is I mean maybe I can play
like h5 or something but I can probably
just continue with my my standard
maneuver so that's probably will be
played at some point so yeah so we have
these ideas we found two of the
potential pieces of / pawns that can
defend there but there's one more guy we
need to include yeah excellent yeah so
92 is what was played in the game and so
the knight is maneuvering to the f5
square and so this was the first time
this move has ever been played and in
the game
his opponent began with sort of the
standard maneuver and night to g3 so now
that the the Knights out of the way he
threw this check in okay you might as
well and here though black already
played a in inaccuracy in the game
Kramnik played Knight to a4 which is is
not the strongest move but okay I mean
it looks it looks decent but Carlsen
just put his night on f5 anyway and the
reason Knight a four isn't a good move
is because there isn't really this
threat because what would white play
here okay and then there's there's two
different possible moves here we can go
back two different ways if you go back
here we can take and bring this rook
over and you can defend with a6 or C or
a5 or c5 but I'm going to be able to
play a three at some point and be able
to take this pawn which will end up
being very good for white the
alternative is to go here and so the
next move for white is pretty obvious
hopefully
King - came to see - King to be three
but let's see if I can trick you OOP
and then rook to see one and if I defend
my my night
here you can just win some material
right so for this reason Knight to a4
didn't stop white from his plan of
installing a knight on f5 so instead he
played King to d7 he's going to go
attack the knight and now white now that
the the b1 Square has been shielded he
has time to play here and that might be
useful in the future if you play a 3 B 4
B 5 with the typical minority attack ok
the rook will be well placed on b1 so we
did attack here and all right now he's
threatening to win the knight but now we
have Bishop to d3 okay and we'll go kind
of quickly through the game because this
is not the full focus but all right
black decides he's going to play c5 he's
needs to get activity somehow here in
this position now g4 alright so yeah he
really controls f5 and also this also
gives them the ability to later move
this Knight to some other key squares
that also are potentially weak here so
that's going to happen - so after c5
then I did go back and after this
capture it's interesting there's a lot
of moves to consider you can take on d4
you can play Knight to f4 he decided to
just take care with the pawn which
threatened this Knight to f4 because if
let's just waste a move for example
Knight to f4 you'd be forced to go to a
light square which would be a bit of a
problem so that's that is the threat so
he he guarded against the threat and but
now yeah h4 and positionally white is
just crushing black here already
so it's a very fantastic play straight
out of the opening bye-bye Carlsen here
ok so he checked and now he wins upon
and yeah so this outside pawn is very
strong we'll just go a few more moves
here and yes oh yeah this is just a very
very strong position for white here
after lots of maneuvering you know all
the pieces store came off he was able at
some point to trade into a winning
endgame here then this was kind of nice
he just played h5 and okay so here he
got to win with a little tactic what was
that White's last last move I think it
was actually move after this but what's
the winning move here what is it Knight
d7 yep and then this was also funny
Kramnik allowed like one spycheck and
they like alright then I resigned ah so
that was kind of funny but it was just a
good opening preparation bye-bye Carlsen
and he just he knew all about it
controlling the f5 square and he just
went for it right away and okay kramnik
snide a four rate at the beginning kind
of doomed him from the start and so he
got a massive positional advantage out
of the opening and went on to win a fine
game there so very good okay and so this
brings us to a one more game that we got
here and then we'll analyze a game that
one of you guys sent in this is one of
my favorite games I've showed it to my
students for years now
it's the game between Rubinstein and
Saul away from the Lodz tournament in
1908 so you might know this have I
showed you this because I've showed
everybody do you know it
I might have okay so we'll get to this
game and we'll do the same thing where
we give you guys some some time to think
at the the critical position
so by transposition it became a tirage
defense and he's Rubinstein so he played
the Rubinstein variation so this was his
innovation in this opening was to put
the bishop on g2 so after he started
doing this it quickly became the main
line and the bishop makes a lot of sense
on g2 where you're attacking the d5 bond
because then you have an
they can attack the d5 pawn your Bishop
attacks d5 after the knight moves
sometimes you take on c5 and then the
Queen is attacking the d5 pawn this
Bishop can go to g5 or it can take one
of the defenders of d5 so that's the the
key point here for White's play so after
a few more moves
he took which is not the most popular
way to play in nowadays people play
Bishop to e7 and the castle and after
here black either takes on d4 or he
plays c4 but okay so in this game he
took on d4 which is not very good
because of the game and he played this
move Queen to b6
and what makes an interesting decision
he takes the night so now the strategy
is not going to be revolving around
attacking the isolated pond because it's
not isolated anymore instead after just
two more moves here this is the position
that we'll take a look at so try again
in this position to identify the key
square that white will be able to fight
for ultimately control and then get a
positional advantage much like in the
game we we just saw right here blaze
these he's going to his first chess
class ever so yeah my sons over there
right now I just heard him come in so
he's going to Andrew Young's class so
that's good that's good all right and so
like last time - I'll go ahead and I'll
give you guys the hint oh oh my god
so here again is the hint so once again
it's it's worth thinking about the
position without any of the pieces on
the board so uh I'll ask the audience
what a what are the weak squares that I
can potentially fight to control here
all right so we have yeah we got c6 c5
and yes so perhaps even if you weren't
able to to find it with the pieces off
the board once you take the pieces off
you know you think about it just the
pawn structure it becomes quite obvious
that you know the open C file is going
to leave a lot of targets here for white
to be able to attack and anyone come in
you want to come in blaze you can open
the door
you gotta pull pull it you gotta pull
come in come in hey blaze it's okay you
can come in you want to come in are you
are you looking
are you learning chess over there yeah
all right good okay good
all right we'll see ya bye bye blaze
alright so we'll go back to our game
okay so here we find ourselves and at
some point we're probably going to want
to attack the CSEC spawn that's that's
going to be a future dream but in
general when you when you do have a
weakness on the C file like this it's
really going to come down to controlling
the square in front of the pond and so
sort of the the three-step plan here for
white to be able to eventually attack
the C pawn is to first control the c5
square so he's going to do that and then
he's going to be able to blockade on c5
and only after all of that's done will
he be able to like double his rooks and
do all sorts of attacking c6 stuff so
what the piece is on now we got to come
up with a plan so first let's try to
identify all the possible moves we could
make that would control c5 as the as the
white pieces here so does anyone have
see any move all right excellent 9a for
Bishop e3 Queen c2 then some rook to c1
excellent so we got lots and lots of
ways and black on his part he is
controlling it twice and he has the
potential for a third but we have the
potential for four so I need to bring my
son back to see if 4 is bigger than
three but in this game oh I decided yes
I can go for c5 and that's why he
allowed this position so what is the
first move
9a for excellent yeah if you play Bishop
III then your B pawn is hanging so Nene
for protects the B pond and you can play
Bishop III next which is what happened
the Queen stayed where she's protecting
c5 and white played Bishop III
okay so black castled and rook to c1 so
now it's white that controls the c5
square so he's going to be able to put
one of his pieces there now so I I like
that this blacks next move really
backfired on him and I wish Lulu were
here so I could tell her that I did this
maneuver against her dad which is
another reason I like this game so for
the moment right he's attacking the e2
pond and he was like yes I provoked you
to play F 3 and then the bishop went to
where it was actually going to go but
this also helps white so you'll notice
the pieces that white still needs to
kind of find a good place for are the
rook and the bishop over here the bishop
is probably even if you do move this
pawn in the future not going to be the
best on this diagonal so it's not going
to happen just quite yet but what is the
maneuver White's going to use to best
make use of these two pieces it's a
excellent yeah real keffe - and Bishop
f1 which is what a is going to happen in
the game and then all of whites pieces
are going to be great and I knew this
game so I got to do this maneuver once
it was good okay and he goes in with the
bishop first ultimately it's the knight
that you're going to want to have on the
c5 square and so it's definitely in your
best interest to trade the dark squared
Bishop because you're fighting for a
dark square and so if you take and I'll
just I'll just take back instead he
protected and we got rook F - with the
point that we can play Bishop F one move
the e pawn reveal an attack on the Queen
and then double our rooks so fantastic
maneuvering okay so now he does want to
take the bishop alright so white traded
because he wants to control the dark
square and now it's black that once
again controls the square so if he's
lucky maybe he can play c5 and if he
gets to move his pawn then it won't be
as weak as it was before so what does
white play now to regain control over c5
Queen d4 excellent which is better than
not Queen to c2 which is you know often
suggested because also you're
controlling at least for the moment this
square so the knight doesn't get to jump
in and shield the C file so Queen d4 is
excellent and after a few moves here
white gets to realize his whole plan
here and he dominates the c5 square so
the the middle game has been a complete
success for white and black is going to
have to passively defend for for a long
time here okay so that trade happened
and you got to double and so now all of
these pawns all of these pieces are
great and in just a minute here - okay
so he's going to add one more attacker
to c6 so yeah it's gonna play b4 b5 so
black stops this with a six but now
there's a second target so he swings his
rook over and
he's he's got pressure on two different
weaknesses and he definitely doesn't
mind if you want to trade Queens that's
that's fine with me
but black tries to go here so you could
you can certainly trade your a6 pawn for
the beet pond but okay a3 just
solidifying and your pawns are still
weak okay and that black tries to go
here and what typically happens in these
positions where one side is completely
dominating the other and has massive
control all the tactics are going to be
in white's favor here and so this
already was a blunder
so what tactical moved in white play in
this position awesome yeah rook takes c6
which wins upon the point is that when
you take here we take the rope and we're
attacking the rook so the rook had to
move and the Queen doesn't let the black
Queen do anything down the C file so as
long as black never gets to like put a
rope gun on the C file or anything then
okay you just have no counter play at
all and then I like what white did to he
just make sure that there's no counter
play for black before he actually does
anything he just plays King to f2 now
probably the most common question I get
asked in this position is well what
happens if we just now play rook to c8
all right it looks looks good right you
control the C file even if we lose the
pond you know what's the big deal
but what would white play here yeah
Bishop takes excellent and yeah so this
this is a success right and then this
would just be a really good for white
one problem is if you go down here you
can't you're not really threatening to
win this because now there's there's
back ranks issues okay so instead you
played h5 you just make sure now there's
never ever going to be any checks on the
C file if you somehow managed to get
your pieces over there so he gets the C
file and he doesn't like black move any
of his bonds so you're just really stuck
here
and waiting as black he tried to a five
which isn't going to help him at all
because now B improves pieces in place B
five and he just pushes and so black
gave it up among other things
we're threatening to just take the
bishop that's our probably our big
threat in this position okay so once
again that was just another example of
if you identified the c5 square
correctly and then you were able to
think about how you could infiltrate
with all of your pieces you had a chance
for a nice strong positional masterpiece
just like this one okay so with that we
conclude the main portion of our lecture
but we did get a game submitted so if
you guys want to keep submitting your
games you can send them to info at st.
Louis chess club org and okay I'll keep
reviewing them I'm happy to do it
this was from a a gentleman named Ivan
our printer isn't working today so I
didn't get to print what he actually
said but it was something along the
lines of he was an unrated player
playing in his first tournament and this
was a game he played against the player
rated 1300 so and uh it was a nice
attacking game and I even had the white
pieces here so we'll go ahead and take a
look at this before we before we leave
today okay 8:45 and we get the Scotch
can west worst nightmare at the Scotch
yeah and here black played sort of an
unusual line which when I did my lecture
I intentionally kept this move out
the most common moves are Knight to f6
and Bishop to c5 but it's also legal to
take the knight on d4 I I didn't cover
this on purpose because nobody
high-rated actually plays this it's not
very popular it doesn't score well and
it's not a very good move so for those
reasons we haven't talked about this
position before and I know there's a lot
of a lot of lower rated games they like
to just trade this right away and then
they think yeah the Queen's right in the
center but the reason you might not want
your Queen on d4 early in the game is
because blacks going to put a knight on
c6 and then your queen is going to have
to move again but that's not going to
happen when you don't have that night
so here the Queen is actually pretty
annoying because it's hard for black to
develop this bishop because as normal
squares are now taken away by the Queen
so ok I quite like White's position and
we won't talk about the Machuca line I
don't want to give away your secrets
here I don't want to give them away but
I looked at it well off the camera we'll
talk about it
okay so d6 Knight to c3 and so the
opening white plays very well so he
develops his pieces here and they they
both castle so we have opposite side
castling and then both sides are going
to race to checkmate each other so okay
I like that a the whites played very
ambitiously
and okay your first tournament and
you're playing to win so so far very
good but here I think white makes his
first inaccuracy in this position he
played the move h4 and you'll notice
this isn't beginner breakdown so I'm
prepared this time that's the difference
from now on I'll actually like pay
attention to your games
it's not a part of the culture of
beginner breakdown but that shows over
you know I don't even remember who
taught that class it's it's over it's
dead
it's only hits only strategy sessions
from here on out but I think okay so
here's what happened in the game is
after h6
he went back to e3 which allows black
the typical move in these sorts of
positions Knight to g4 where it's a big
success for black if he can pick up the
bishop on e3
so that in mind I think it made a little
bit more sense here for white to start
with the move like f3 and this was
indeed a part of his plan
the whole time because then you can play
g4 and h4 and checkmate
so I mean here this would give you the
square and now there's no Knight to g4
but as it happened in the game black did
not play Knight to g4
but I would like to make one blunder
here as white so if I try to save my
bishop by going here
what would black play in this position
our audience is on fire tonight I have
to have to come up with some some harder
puzzles yeah and then you can't you're
gonna move your queen and I'm on here
okay but uh as it were that didn't
happen and then also here I think white
didn't play as accurately as possible so
I think you should play f3 he played
Bishop to e2 which might be okay but in
conjuncture with his next move which is
f3 this move doesn't make as much sense
so let's see it was here and f3 so I
don't think in this position we actually
know where we want that Bishop to be
it's probably not behind our RF pawn
because we're going to put our pawns on
these like squares so e2 is probably not
the right square for the bishop so we
don't know where it's going to go it
might come out this way might come out
this way to trade for this guy we don't
know just yet so I would just keep them
here because this also gives black in
additional tempo to start his own attack
so everybody's going to push all their
pawns on both sides King b1 also
probably wasn't necessary it's okay it's
a nice little bit nicer square for the
King but uh you probably just could have
got on with it with g4 okay and so c5
and the Queen goes back to d2 this is a
very good square for the Queen because
now you always have to be on alert for
taking here on h6
so it's kind of unfortunate for black
that he played the move h6 especially
because he didn't follow it up by taking
the dark squared bishop it only only
made sense to play this move if you were
able to go get this guy otherwise you're
just creating a hook so g4 g5 will force
white to be able to open up one of the
files here for the King and now you also
have to be on guard for sacrifices on h6
and okay maybe black should just play
like b4 here every move should be as
forceful as possible get those pawns
down as quickly as possible
he played Queen to c7 which is not like
a bad square or anything but it's
it's all about time here you want to
play as forcefully as possible and now
it's interesting he white played the
move that I assumed I would just play g4
very logical and you want to play g5 but
it's also should be considered whether
or not this sacrifice works so during a
game and it was presumably a standard
rated game this is something you know
you would want to look at rather
seriously and now I can stump the class
let's take this in this and now White
has a threat so let's make a nothing
move for black we'll see if you guys can
identify White's threat in this position
so hopefully this this time I'll get you
for sure
yes never mind okay never mind doesn't
work unless it does all right good job
Ken West all right good job
yep so ken west blundering his pieces
then rescinding his move but you played
the best move yeah so yeah he must have
seen this this position it realized
that's a good move but uh yeah as he as
he figured out yeah so if you take here
we take back and this is a huge threat
so okay so very good very good Ken West
that's why he's a grandmaster he doesn't
even have to he just plays the best move
and he doesn't know why that's why
that's why he's a grandmaster okay but
uh okay instead g4 also very strong it
just looks like whites attack it's just
going to be much faster here which is
what ended up happening so b4 very good
now black has to choose how he wants to
take you took with the night okay
I like it and so now yeah so if you play
g5 now he'll just play h5 and then don't
try to play g6 and just make sure you
can't break through on the Kings side so
I guess what would the what would the
audience play here h5 is a is a very
good move sort of like the first thing
that I thought of each but h5 because
then you can play g5 and this is a very
good plan in whites attack will be
faster in this line but he played a move
Ivan did that he should be really proud
of because I let my computer think for a
long time and it didn't find this move
but then I told it and said yeah that's
a good move so so this movie should be
proud of he did go in for the sacrifice
and and it does just work his opponent
you know didn't accept but ok you should
you should probably accept it that's
probably the critical way to play here
and then
if the problem is White's threat now is
a Bishop to d3 so you have to somehow
stop that if you go here then you'll get
you play like here and are even if you
even if you protect this like we're
coming here and this should be a quick
mate here for for white so so very good
very good
his opponent did not accept so you went
in you robbed the pawn and they didn't
take it so it's probably time to retreat
instead he played a dubious move here
Queen to f4 much better is just to bring
the bishop back and obviously I don't
mind if you open the H file please
please open the H file and yeah I mean
so you're just threatening to double the
pawns he doesn't want to trade with you
so this would have been a much better
way to play but as it were he went here
which should have allowed black to get
away with the move here Bishop to e5 so
this move should have been played almost
automatically and now white is wasting a
little bit of time not getting on with
his attack and then you know if we were
grandmasters this what happened but okay
but instead I supported played a5 which
he he probably doesn't have have the
most time for an Bishop to d3 with a
threat that apparently black didn't see
because now he he blunders and okay I
mean probably probably you should play a
move like c4 or something because you
see what White's threat is and then you
can either block the e-file or you could
go to f5 and if you take I might take
with my Jeep on to open the G file but I
guess you didn't see White's threat but
does the audience see it
yeah yeah just sort of the simple
Queenie for with with a threat and okay
you got to play the move g6 and it's
kind of upsetting that the best move is
to take the rook you know you want to
play a move like h4 and leave your
awesome Bishop there but he made the
right decision he he took the rook so
very good and that's kind of hard to do
just because you like that Bishop a lot
but he made the right decision
his opponent took with the king and okay
so yeah you can either start putting
rooks on the e-file or you can play h5
here which again so black can play as
accurately as possible he just went back
better is to play this move again you
know you should keep putting that Bishop
on e5 and only if here you go back and
then you have to decide what you're
doing with your Queen so that happened
and there's more than one good plan you
can double on the e-file you can play h5
and you can take the pondo so all right
very good
and so here white is just completely
winning and you can win bring your books
to the e-file er or play h5 it's up to
you this is how he chose to win and yeah
so how many attacks d6 he really
understands pins you got to give him
that it's a deep understanding of pins
which is very unfortunate if you're
you're black in this position and there
are a among other moves okay this is
this is very strong he runs away and
okay this is just a sexist Queen which
obviously isn't the best but I mean okay
he's getting crushed marry and so now
yes just over and he pushes his pawn and
black gave it up right here so a very
strong attacking game by uh by the white
pieces here so thanks for sending it in
this was a truly good game and for your
first tournament to play such a an
aggressive and attacking game is that is
really a good sign for the future of
your chests career here so yeah keep
sending in your games if you have
requests for any strategical concepts
you'd like to see talked about on the
show
snow hit like share subscribe and thanks
everybody for coming out tonight